es ist bei uns in deutschland übrigens
bis heute die zahl wird weniger bis
heute wird die these vertreten putin ist
vom westen von der nato in die enge
getrieben wurden überhaupt kein alibi
geben putin aggressiv zu werden die
gegenüber den nachbarn die sogenannten
putin vorsteher heißen zu unrecht putin
verstehen denn sie verstehen putin gar
nicht auch heute noch gibt es ja bei uns
persönlichkeiten die ernsthaft die
ansicht vertreten der westen trage eine
mitschuld durch die nato eingekesselt
seit putin gar nichts anderes übrig
geblieben als militärische gewalt
gegenüber den nachbarn auszuüben die die
das sagen haben putin überhaupt nicht
verstanden denn den einmarsch in der
ukraine hat er gar nicht mit der nato
osterweiterung begründet sondern mit der
tatsache dass für ihn putin die ukraine
ein russischer staat sei dass die
ukraine zu russland gehören das ein
historischer fehler gewesen sei die
ukraine in die souveränität zu entlassen
was um himmels willen hat die
völkerrechtswidrige annexion der krim
mit der nato ostarbeiter und zu tun was
hat der einmarsch in bonn bad mit der
nato osterweiterung zu tun was hat die
unterdrückung der opposition mit der
nato zu tun was hat die ermordung von
regimekritikern auch bei uns in
deutschland mit der nato zu tun nichts
das hat etwas mit einem totalitären
machtanspruch von guten zu tun er viel
mehr angst vor der demokratie in seinem
land hat als von der nato von der
demokratie muss er auch angst haben denn
wenn russland eine demokratie in unserem
sinne würde wäre es das ende der
herrschaft von putin
ich glaube es ist immer schwieriger von
kunden verstehen zu sprechen denn kaum
jemand der auf putins seite oder
zumindest als putin verstehe er sich zu
erkennen gegeben hatte hat das was jetzt
passiert es vorher gesagt wir haben
glaube ich in dieser putin kunde eine
zeitenwende sowie auch sonst in europa
und wir haben auch in russland das
gefühl des so bekomme ich das von außen
mit dass immer mehr menschen gar nicht
wissen wer überhaupt noch in direkten
kontakt mit putin steht er soll jetzt ja
angefangen haben auch seine engste
umgebung an zu schreien ob das stimmt
wer weiß das schon aber jedenfalls die
zahl der mädchen verstehe in russland
nimmt auch ab welche nächsten schritte
von putin zu erwarten sind kann glaube
ich niemand wirklich sagen und alles was
uns bleibt es zu versumpfen russland
versteher zu bleiben zumindest zu
verstehen wie dieses land funktioniert
und da ist es natürlich klar der glaube
an die demokratie der glaube an die
westlichen werte ist in russland in der
bevölkerung nicht tief verwurzelt der
glaube an die nato an friedensmacht ist
in der russischen bevölkerung nicht die
verwurzelt und dort zumindest wird die
nato von vielen immer noch als bedrohung
wahrgenommen ist man damit schon gut ihn
verstehe ich weiß es nicht aber für mich
ist das eine klare tatsachen nach vielen
gesprächen mit russen die das so klar
sagen und das müssen wir einfach zur
kenntnis nehmen und hoffen dass das
besser wird aber es ist doch wohl auch
so dass die die innere russische
stimmung nach der annexion der krim pro
putin viel größer war als heute und man
krieg gegen die ukraine man muss
wirklich sagen diese grenze die putin
hier überschritten hat ist auch eine
grenze innerhalb der herzen vieler
russischer menschen so viele menschen
sehen kiew ganz anders als die krim sie
so viele menschen hat die ukraine eine
tiefe möglich im herzen sitzende
bedeutung und ein angriff auf die
ukraine wird doch ganz anders beurteilt
und auch wenn wir die zahlen nicht genau
kennen noch nicht genau kennen ist jetzt
schon klar eine zustimmung wie bei der
grimm wird münchen nicht bekommen die
frage ist ja auch kann überhaupt der
wille nach freiheit oder das gefühl frei
zu sein in russland entstehen mit blick
auf die medien repressalien als wir
haben unser reporter peter thiede ist
vor ort und ja dann menschen mal gezeigt
hier dort herrscht krieg die wussten das
gar nicht und da muss ich sagen wie kann
man sich denn überhaupt in russland
vielleicht frei entfalten wenn man gar
nicht die medien konsumieren kann man
kann es natürlich schon das internet ist
offen und jetzt wird immer mehr
zugemacht und über jahre konnte man auch
die nowaja gaseta an jedem kiosk kaufen
die auch in der ukrainischen ausgabe
rausgekommen ist als dieser krieg begann
und gegen die immer mehr vorgegangen
wird viele wollten es nun nicht viele
wolken den bequemen weg gehen unsere
regierung macht es richtig die feinde
sind draußen und wenn ich mir zu viele
fragen stelle dann muss ich auch darauf
daraus seine konsequenzen ziehen da muss
ich auf die straße gehen aber wenn ich
auf die straße gehe muss ich auch ins
gefängnis gehen wollen ich glaube viele
verdrängen ist einfach gern und leben
einfach nur ihr leben weil sie wissen
wenn ich mich in die politik einmischen
wird konsequenzen haben paul verdrängen
ist eigentlich ein gutes stichwort du
hast ja sehr sehr früh davor gewarnt was
passieren wird muss man sagen selbst mir
kam es manchmal in film nach acht runden
so vor dass ich dachte damit würde er
nicht recht haben worüber reden wir
jetzt sie gerade am tisch und alles ist
eingetroffen was du voraus gesagt hast
da gegenüber am tisch es habe ja auch
schon westliche geheimdienste auch
gewarnt früher wie schlimm ist es jetzt
eigentlich für dich und vor allem
natürlich für die menschen in der
ukraine das eigentlich nichts getan
wurde und das ist so viele putin
verstärkt die putin gar nicht verstanden
hatten
janina ich hätte lieber nicht recht
gehabt mit dem was ich berichtet habe
oder kommentiert habe wir müssen sagen
wir bei bild seit vielen vielen jahren
angefangen im syrien krieg werden der
ehemalige chefredakteur julian reichelt
dort berichtet hatte das ganze ebenfalls
immer sehr klar benannt hat dazu andere
kollegen wir haben immer eine klare
klare haltung dort gezeigt und ich
glaube für mich als reporter war 2014
klar in welche richtung das gehen würde
dann wladimir putin hat schon damals
gesagt dass hier auf dem majdan
ausschließlich nazis seien hat davon
gesprochen dass die kirche regierung aus
nazis bestimmt also hat dieses narrativ
was auch heute wieder nutzt damals schon
geformt und es war abzusehen dass er
wenn er nicht gestoppt würde auf diesem
weg weitergeht und du hast es ja
angesprochen das ist ja alles kein
geheimnis gewesen wie er auf die ukraine
blickt von daher ist es für die menschen
schon wirklich
will ich sagen enttäuschend ist
wahrscheinlich nicht genug und frust
auch nicht ist ist
eine große traurigkeit auch darüber dass
man damit recht behalten hat und ein
großes drama muss man sagen denn
menschen sterben jetzt kann man sagen
was wäre passiert wenn der westen früher
härter zugeschlagen hätte ich glaube das
hätte dazu geführt dass möglicherweise
ist diesen krieg nicht gegeben hätte das
lässt sich aber nicht beweisen von daher
sind wir jetzt in dieser situation in
der wir sind und da fragen sich auch
viele menschen hier in der ukraine tut
denn deutschland wirklich genug also
nehmen wir die waffenlieferungen die
sehr spät gekommen sind die sind anstatt
geplant am sonntag dann offenbar in
altenstadt geplant am samstag erst am
montag los und stand heute nachmittag
waren sie noch immer in polen also ich
glaube dass uns dennoch und jan hat ja
recht dass der westen durchaus sinn ins
aktion gesteht aber deutschland dann in
der umsetzung immer mal wieder die
entschlossenheit fehlt also sachen
lieferung ist ein gutes stichwort ich
habe mich geirrt ich gebe das auch gerne
zu ich habe immer gesagt die
waffenlieferung in die ukraine sind
etwas was wir wirklich und sehr genau
überlegen sollten wer weiß was passiert
wenn wir das machen dann kam der große
angriff und die ukrainische armee trotz
acht jahren vorbereitung ihr fehlte es
an vielen vielen arten von material und
wie häufig habe ich mich dann gefragt
wenn sie jetzt in hinreichende anzahl
diese boden-luft-raketen gehabt hätten
diese panzerabwehrraketen gehabt hätten
dann wäre dieser dieses vorrücken der
russischen armee wahrscheinlich noch
früher und effizienter gestoppt worden
du hast da falsch gelegen und da muss
ich auch wirklich sagen ich konnte es
mir nicht vorstellen aber ja es war ein
fehler jetzt haben sich glaube ich hier
in deutschland polen das knüpft an das
was du sagst auch viel zu viele
politiker immer um
die größte demokratie auf der welt
gekümmert und immer geschaut was da
eigentlich falsch läuft nämlich um
amerika also es gibt hier diesen großen
oder latenten amerika hast in der
deutschen politik das muss man sagen und
es war glaube ich für viele viel
entscheidender zu gucken was da im
bundesstaat kalifornien falsch läuft
oder in oregon stadt zu gucken was läuft
eigentlich in einer demokratie hier mehr
oder weniger für unsere vor unserer
haustür und welche aggressor sitzt
eigentlich noch ein paar kilometer
weiter und bedroht diese demokratie das
haben einfach viele ausgeblendet und
praxis gerade auch immer wieder gesagt
wenn ich sehe wer von den deutschen
politikern auch aus der sozialdemokratie
gerne sich gezeigt hat mit einem
außenminister wolf oder auch damit
kokettiert hat das ist gute kontakte zu
putin geht gibt dann ist das wirklich
beschämend und ich hoffe dass es hier
nichts los der spd ja
aber das ist hier insgesamt ein ende und
wenn wir mit peter altmaier sehen wie
ein werk wie peter altmaier und werk
aufgebaut hat da gibt es bilder wieder
putin an lacht also die schüler auch aus
der union und am ende ja auch angela
merkel die diese politik mitverfolgt hat
es gibt sich das ist vollkommen richtig
absolut richtiger hinweis dass wir das
ist nicht nur sozialdemokraten waren wir
sehen auch viele politiker von der ard
von der linkspartei man kann das
eigentlich fast sagen durch alle im
bundestag vertretenen parteien gab es
große annäherung oder gab es zum teil
zumindest echte annäherung auch an
wladimir putin und sehr viel verständnis
für ihn und seine art zu agieren und ich
glaube es muss jetzt auch in dieser
situation einfach klar sein wo die echte
demokratie sitzt und wo die echten
freunde sind und die sitzen in amerika
und das am ende auch die einzigen die
das nato-bündnis dann zu einem bündnis
machen was wirklich seinen sinn und den
zweck erfüllt nämlich ein
verteidigungsbündnis zu sein ohne
amerika wäre die nato gar nicht
einsatzfähig
vielleicht nur ein kleiner hinweis von
von der seite wir wollen gerne auch
gerade vor dem hintergrund unserer
geschichte friedensmacht sein das ist
auch in ordnung und die bundesregierung
hat sich das glaube ich mir alle mühe
gegeben ohne waffen lieferungen in die
ukraine den konflikt zu befrieden also
das gilt für den kanzler das gilt für
die außenministerin das findet alles bei
mir großen respekt aber wir haben viel
zu lange dem narrativ angehangen frieden
schaffen ohne waffen geht auch wir haben
doch die bundeswehr mitte der 50er jahre
nicht gegründet um andere länder
anzugreifen und zu überfallen haben die
bundeswehr gegründet um durch die
mitgliedschaft in der nato unsere lage
unser land vor angriffen zu schützen das
ist eine große friedensbewegung die
bundeswehr hat noch nie ein land
angegriffen und überfallen um dieses
land zu unterjochen oder zu besetzen und
jetzt in diesen tagen jetzt nachdem wir
100 milliarden paket beschlossen haben
im bundestag dass das kommen soll
sprechen wir bei der taxonomie
verordnung darüber ob
rüstungsbetrieben nachhaltig sind
antwort der kommission nein wir wollen
ihnen den zugang zum kapitalmarkt
erschwerend wir alle wären heilfroh wenn
es diese waffen nicht gäbe wenn wir
frieden hätten auf der welt ohne waffen
aber ja wir haben im oktober vor einem
jahr vor anderthalb jahren haben wir
über feministische außenpolitik
gesprochen in ordnung also doch mal über
realistische außenpolitik die welt ist
nicht friedlich es gibt zu viele
barbaren an den sportarten lehrern ein
argument erklären wenn man wenn man wenn
man waffen nicht in ein krisengebiet
liefert dann frage ich mich wofür
braucht man dann also dass ein hund also
werde ich eigentlich demokratie ist wir
verstehen dass wenn man sagt nicht in
ein krisengebiet in eine militärdiktatur
wie ägypten ist das voll in ordnung aber
wann brauche ich waffen ich brauchte
waffen dann wenn eine krise herrscht
wozu brauche ich sonst waffen also
verteidigungswaffen und das ist ja das
ist das argument hatte schnell wir nie
erschlossen zu sagen die ukraine eine
demokratie steht dabei zu sterben aber
der aggressor wir lassen die beiden
sozusagen sich allein überlassen sie
sich alleine es ist sind sogar gelassen
das ist ein unterschied ob man abwehr
defensivwaffen liefert oder warfen die
den zweck haben andere länder zu erobern
eine boden-luft-rakete damit können sie
kein anderes land erobern damit können
sie angriffe aus der luft ab wäre der
gedanke der politische gedanke war wir
wollen alles unterlassen was der
gegenseite anlass bieten könnte
militärisch hat auch gegen deutschland
vorzugehen deswegen werden wir ja auch
durch die waffenlieferung nicht zu einer
partei in diesem konflikt anders wäre es
wenn auch nato-soldaten in der ukraine
stehen würden ergibt sich für mich keine
logik wenn ich eine demokratie dann
nicht mit waffen unterstützen darf wenn
wenn es wenn ein diktator jetzt das land
jetzt gott sei dann aber hat carla oder
sehr spät hat lange gedauert ja auch
weil die anderen mit obacht noch uns
überhaupt nicht mehr verstanden haben
wir glauben ja oft immer andere länder
belehren zu müssen weil wir das
angeblich besser wissen